on ne sait pas quand ou même si les
travailleurs seront de retour sur les
chantiers des habitations trigone c'est
une véritable douche froide pour rennes
boulianne qui est locataire dans un
immeuble de mascouche dont la
construction n'est pas encore terminée
vraiment pas drôle parce que nous quand
on est arrivé ici on pensait que tout
serait fini mais y avait déjà perdu leur
licence il y avait déjà été arrêté vice
de construction aux structures opaques
semant la confusion chez ses clients la
régie du bâtiment a révoqué les dix neuf
licences des habitations trigone en
septembre dernier l'entreprise les
ensuite récupéré le temps de porter sa
cause en appel un appel qu'elle vient de
perdre devant le tribunal administratif
du travail ces chantiers sont donc
arrêté de nouveau qe au pré campagne
j'ai un arrêt mais ce que ce soit fini
selon la régie du bâtiment une dizaine
de projets en cours sont touchés mais on
ignore combien d'unités exactement il
pourrait y en avoir des centaines ou
même plus pour le moment les clients
sont dans l'incertitude la plus totale
ils devront vérifier leur contrat pour
voir quelles sont leurs protections rbq
ne détient pas ces informations là
quelle est la nature du contrat et tout
les détails est ce que le bâtiment est
couvert par un plan de garantie le
nouveau plan de garantie de construction
résidentielle s'impliquera 3 triplex en
construction à laval et qui n'ont pas
encore été livrés les clients auront
deux possibilités
c'est vraiment le remboursement des
acomptes jusqu'à un maximum de 50 mille
dollars et il ya le parachèvement des
travaux jusqu'à un maximum effectivement
de 200 300 millions d'euros selon le kof
qui s'appelait mais on ne sait pas si
habitations trigone a souscrit à des
plans de garanties pour ses immeubles de
plus de quatre étages puisque c'est
facultatif en vertu d'une loi entrée en
vigueur en janvier 2020 les dépôts des
acheteurs doivent cependant être
remboursés en totalité
ce sera en quelque sorte un premier test
pour cette nouvelle disposition on n'a
aucun moyen de savoir quel point ça a
été respectée par les promoteurs et
est-ce qu en pratique ça va fonctionner
et pour les immeubles en construction la
suite des choses pourraient être plus
compliquées va falloir voir c'est
comment tu rigoles bouchehr est sûre
parce que c'est le plus droite
construire logiquement au falloir qu à
face construit par quelqu'un d'autre
voir qu'à vendre ses participations dans
les différents projets d'auto
entrepreneur impossible de savoir ces
habitations trigone ira en appel pour
récupérer ses 10 ans l'entreprise n'a
pas donné suite à nos demandes
d'entrevue il se lie viebacher
radio-canada mascouche